you insultingly call ryan gosling's
character a ken doll i do but like now
he really did play kenneth look see so
lord knows what's up he can see into the
future you know how does it feel now
knowing you you beat up ken
right well we beat each other up you
know i feel like it's kind of an even
match brian's photos as can have gone
viral in the jean vest the denim vest
shirtless the abs the ken underwear oh
yeah how did you two react to those
photos was there ken underwear oh you
didn't
yeah that's great
you know what's funny my brother's in
the movie my younger brother's in the
movie he is
okay well then he really knows yeah he
knows all about okay but those photos
have your approval they do definitely
yeah they've been approved
lloyd
i got an urgent locate and destroy
that could be fun the man's got some
street cred you guys this movie is it's
so good i didn't breathe for two hours
except when i was laughing because the
action sequences are so good it's so
funny what was it like for you two to be
back together again and make this fun
film after another great one knives out
then we back together for once i was
gonna say we don't have much in this
movie together so i mean the movie
itself was fantastic but but in terms of
our interaction it was very enjoyable
for me though because i got to shoot him
in the butt she did shoot me in the ass
yeah sometimes i throw up in his face
sometimes i shoot exactly
that's a relationship how does that make
you feel well it's great it's good every
time i know anna's in the movies
something horrible is gonna happen to me
i just don't know what it's gonna be how
exciting and you've got another one
coming up soon ghosted yeah that's right
how can you top it you're just gonna
have to wait and see on that one
well another reunion for you chris with
the incredible russo brothers what is it
about the action films that they make
the movies that they make that just
makes it a winning combination well it's
that they understand the genre you know
what i mean there's a million
directing is
problem solving what it really is you're
gonna have a plan but once you're on the
day you have to kind of move quickly and
and and their understanding of action
films allows them to move quickly
through problems effortlessly and
communicate what they want to achieve uh
to the different departments based on
that knowledge so it's it's a really
uh it's a comforting feeling as an actor
thank you i just learned about directing
things
came out all right it's great
you both have also trained i mean you
trained for bond trained for a little
while called captain america how would
the training you've done in the past
compared to training for this movie was
it more was it more intense you get to
fight and not in a gown this time which
is probably not correct well to me it
was another level of training for bond i
barely had time to prepare for it um
which went well with the character uh
for this one equally i wanted to this
character is completely different she
has military background experience she
has to be you know i wanted to go
through that process to feel like i knew
what i was doing and feel confident and
in my oh you know so it was months
months of training done shooting and and
and
uh rehearsals with ryan and the news the
choreographies the stuns i mean it was
it wasn't it was a lot of hard work and
discipline there's no way around it you
just have to learn it and put the time
and the hours and
show up every day
and still when you do it and you work
with the second unit which is the action
unit and and then the ruses would watch
it they would not be happy with it and
then you have to go back and repeat
most of it and and make it because
that's what he was saying like they know
what they want they're so sure about
every single bit of the movie yeah and
when it doesn't click you just have to
do it again and you gotta get it right
you're pissed because you're in pain and
you're exhausted but then
it all makes sense and you have three
ribs out of place four four four ribs
yeah but she powers through it but you
know wow you know okay
your ribs that's like most of them
right
how many ribs do you have
that's it
yeah wow that's all okay i don't even
know how to respond to that it's pain
scale out of 10 yeah oh yeah that's okay
that's a 10. no but she but she shows up
and she does the work and it's
impressive she's a killer yeah all right
well chris how did training for captain
america compare to training for lloyd
hanson who would win in a fight out of
uh cap and lloyd it's gotta be cap come
on hey listen i played cap way too long
to decide against him i was gonna be cap
bucky
[Music]
that is america's
but you gotta you gotta respect lloyd's
outlook you gotta respect the man that
he is even though he's
a sociopath a little bit a little bit
but but but he's himself you know he's
unapologetically himself and um fun for
you to play very much so for that reason
and that you know it's not necessarily
that he's a bad guy because i don't
think bad guys see themselves as bad
guys um he sees himself as
probably necessary more than anything
else
but but that kind of
freedom
to try and buck social norms and
propriety is what makes it fun to to
play them every day i have to ask you
about a different blonde we're so
excited to see you on blonde yeah we
have yeah me too i have so much in
common with ryan we've both been blonde
[Music]
[Laughter]
what can we expect from the movie ann
have to ask did you get to wear any of
maryland's real clothes because we just
saw kim kardashian do that
uh
uh what can you expect i i don't know
what i
definitely know
the movie is not what people is i don't
know what people are expecting but this
is definitely going to be something very
surprising and
a more intimate
uh take on her life and her journey as a
norma jean and then the movie start that
she became
and we did not
use anything real we
got a wonderful team of
tailors and seamstress and we recreated
every single piece
the same as
you know the ones she wore but yeah we
did not touch
any of her real stuff
[Music]
you